OK — so, if you’re here you probably watched
our breakdown of Technicolor.
If not, I’ll put the link up here somewhere.
I wanted to make this video to cover some
of the things that I didn’t have time to
put in that video, some of the research and
footnotes, and also to thank the people who
helped us make that video.
In this case, that would be Eastman House
— their museum that you can go to, you can
find them online — and they were really
generous with their time, their knowledge,
and also a lot of the images that you see
in the video.
And I also want to thank the Smithsonian of
course, which let us talk to their curator
— also very knowledgeable — and get in
there and film that giant Technicolor camera
and the gorgeous ruby slippers.
I got to film those ruby slippers myself,
so I think, basically, I’m like a legendary
Hollywood cameraman now, because I’ve shot
those ruby slippers.
Um, just a theory.
Anyway, let’s get to it.
Let’s watch the video and I’ll tell you
what we had to leave out and what we really
wanted to put in.
So yeah, obviously this video is centered
around Dorothy and the Wizard of Oz.
I have to tell you that I’m a person who
believed some of these misconceptions before
I started making this video.
I may have known that it wasn’t the first
Technicolor video, but I didn’t know the
degree to which Technicolor shaped the movie.
I did think that there was some sort of technological
breakthrough there, but it was largely a marketing
breakthrough.
They really sold this movie as a Technicolor
movie because it cost them a lot of money
to make that way.
There were other movies beforehand or in contemporaneous
production that also used Technicolor.
So, this is an important thing to clear up.
And this whole video just sprang from my curiosity
— why does Technicolor look like that?
And it turned out to be more complex than
I thought.
Yeah, so, sorry to slam the Maryland Science
Center, but what are you gonna do?
They said it.
OK, so, please look at Barbara Flückiger
website, because it shows you how complex
all this color theory is and also how much
people who know about photography care about
the depth and history of their discipline.
There are so many little gradations that are
fascinating to look at.
OK, I have to tell you one thing I left out
about Kalmus and Comstock.
Before they got into Technicolor, they developed
other camera nerd projects, and one of their
early projects was actually a speed camera,
like the kind that catches speeders on the
road, and apparently it worked.
This is the early 1900s, but they weren’t
able to sell it to any police departments,
probably because they didn’t understand
it.
But could have been a whole different 20th
century if they’d stuck with that speed
camera idea instead of moving on to Technicolor.
Ah yes!
This is Flowers and Trees which is so cool
looking.
I am not a gamer myself but there’s this
game out called Cuphead now that is inspired
by the animation styles of these 1930s Technicolor
movies.
You should look it up on YouTube because they
have a really good emulation of this animation
style.
It looks great and it makes you understand
animation better.
OK, so this is my Technicolor breakdown.
This is the full page of that Technicolor
diagram that I showed.
Now, already there’s a lot of different
methods, so when I talk about two-strip and
three-strip here, I’m kind of condensing
a bunch of different processes into one most
significant step from two-strip to three-strip.
An analogy that I thought of was if in the
year 2100, they were covering the iPhone,
they wouldn’t cover iPhone, iPhone 4, iPhone
4s, iPhone 5, iPhone 5s, or whatever the proper
gradations are, they would just say there
were Blackberries, then there were iPhones,
then there were Androids.
They would kind of give you the bigger picture,
and that’s what I’m doing here with Technicolor.
I’m kind of giving you the bigger picture
of the switch to three-strip.
There were all sorts of processes within that
that you can look up and see the differences
between them, both in the technology and in
the results.
And so for these simulations, it was fun because
in After Effects I went through and I did
actually properly tint the things with cyan,
tint the things with green, and then actually
layer them on top of one another.
So I didn’t just replace it with the original
picture at the end, this is a proper combination
of all those colors, and that kinda helped
me get a grasp on it too, to have to do it
the right way.
That helped me understand how this stuff actually
worked (with the help of the people I talked
to).
Generally, the key, which I show there, I
heard generally it stopped being used after
1945.
One of the reasons they would use it is because
of blurring, also because it was really hard
to get the three strips in exactly the right
place, so sometimes they’d be just a little
bit off — a micrometer off, or what we would
call a pixel today off — and so a key could
help kind of settle them into place.
Lock them into place over that black and white
image.
Yeah, so I was amazed — Ryan at the Smithsonian
told me about this, that was the first time
I had heard about it and thought that was
an amazing piece of trivia there.
Even though they did have mattes at the time,
which is what I do here with my hand on the
little box, they painted this room sepia because
that was the easiest way to use the camera
continuously for the shot.
That’s just really crazy and you can see
it if you watch it, you can see that it’s
a different camera filming that scene.
Yes, and here’s the gloriously large Technicolor
camera.
Ryan was super smart, really helped me understand
this process better.
My greatest pleasure though was enjoying the
historical irony of filming this gigantic
camera with my tiny Sony camera.
Literally, it’s this big.
I’m using it to film this right now.
And I’m filming this thing that the best
filmmakers in the world, in history too, had
to use, and I’m able to film in 4k, grading
at will, with just this tiny little camera.
So, it’s just amazing to me and bizarre
to get to do that.
Again these cameras were super loud — they
had to really adjust around that.
That’s Jimmy Stewart, clown right there.
The press materials say “It was always Jimmy’s
dream to play a clown.”
I never knew that about him, hadn’t really
heard about that movie, even though it’s
famous.
So yeah, this is a great scene.
Eastman House gave me this strip and these
prints from Singin’ in the Rain and it was
really fun to match them up with the scenes
in
the movie.
Bobbie Koshay — she’s really cool.
We couldn’t find a photo that we could license
in time for this video, but if you look her
up, you can find some pictures of her testing
out different dresses I think, and there’s
also one of her with the body double for the
Scarecrow, and it’s really fun to look at
and compare because Judy Garland as Dorothy
is so iconic, and then you see this other
person who looks a little like her, but isn’t
her — it’s really fun to see.
The slippers were originally silver — I
know that a lot of the people who think the
Wizard of Oz is about the fight between the
gold and the silver standard point to these
silver slippers as evidence of that theory
about the work.
I asked Ryan about that — he was sort of
uncertain exactly where that theory is right
now.
There’s some people apparently who don’t
believe it, some who do think it’s true,
that it was about the fight over the gold
standard.
But that was a little too much historical
baggage to weigh in on this video.
So we just left it out, but you can look it
up and you can find a lot of information out
there.
So here’s Natalie Kalmus — here I showed
the credits for Gone With the Wind.
She actually fought a lot on that movie because
she wanted more extreme colors.
She didn’t like the muted browns that were
being used, so she could definitely be difficult
to tangle with sometimes, which I think makes
her interesting, because it shows the power
of the Technicolor Company that she could
go around and basically tell directors what
to do on their own movies, because Technicolor
was that powerful and using color was that
new that they were ready to believe her.
And Technicolor really endured for a while.
Ultimately it was ease, but it was also expense
of the process that doomed the traditional
process that we recognize and that we describe
here.
It was just really pricey to process these
films, to do that dye transfer process, and
so the company changed.
Technicolor is definitely still around today,
but it is a different company and it doesn’t
use that three-strip process.
There are some minor exceptions of when the
three-strip process has been used after the
Godfather Part II, which is about to come
up here — there it is — so after that,
there were some minor exceptions of revivals
or restorations in which they did do a three-strip
process, but for the most part it’s gone.
So it’s fair enough to say that it doesn’t
exist.
Yeah, and then, today we have this whole world
of digital color grading — besides me complaining
about the dust clouds of Trapcode Particular
plugin in Stranger Things.
It kind of got its start in O Brother Where
Art Thou, and in The Aviator, Martin Scorsese
actually graded the scenes digitally to echo
the Technicolor process that was used in the
year in which the movie was set.
So he has in the early scenes of the movie
he has a two-strip looking thing; in the later
years, he has a three-strip looking thing.
To my modern eyes, it doesn’t look like
they did that great a job with it.
But that’s for your judgment whether you
think it accurately simulates the Technicolor
look.
I think because Kalmus wasn’t there and
the Technicolor wasn’t there, it’s more
of an homage than an exact emulation.
And yeah, that’s it.
I’ve talked through the end of the video.
It also brought us forward to this world of
digital color grading, which is what exists
today, it’s what I’ll use on this video,
and it’s very different.
So yeah, I just wanted to make this video
to kind of get into some of the things that
we had to leave out.
The world of Technicolor is way more complex
than this, and this was ten minutes long,
so the outro to that video was me kind of
talking through why this video had to be so
long.
Because I went in and I said I want to just
use After Effects to show people how three-strip
and two-strip worked, and that ended up being
a chunk of it, but it was way more complex
than that.
Which is really cool.
It’s not just a technological story, it’s
a cultural story of this company that had
a lot of power and these people who were learning
how to use color.
And that’s what I think makes it interesting.
So thank you for watching.
Please take this opportunity to nerd out more
on Technicolor.
Visit Barbara Flueckiger’s website, visit
Eastman House, both in person and online,
whatever you can do.
And if you can’t do that, if you aren’t
interested in learning any more Technicolor
details, look up one of these old movies and
just marvel at them.
Check out Singin’ in the Rain, see The Adventures
of Robin Hood, or look up some of the old
cartoons.
One of the slides that I have in there is
from a Woody Woodpecker cartoon that was in
Technicolor, and they’re gorgeous.
They really do have a unique look and a unique
use of color that is just wonderful to hang
out with for a few hours.
So, thanks for watching and hopefully you’ll
enjoy it.